here in the courts labs we only work on
the most important scientific problems
like
what if we nuke stuff or how about we
make this elephant explode or
who could forget look at this thing it's
really big
continuing this proud tradition let's
explore the scientific mystery of what
would happen to you
if earth suddenly turned into gold the
midas apocalypse
based on the ancient tale of king midas
who was cursed
so everything he touched turned into
gold
before we can explore this scenario with
science we'll first define the premise
midas's curse is a very special
phenomenon called
magic which allows us to modify physics
so what happens when midas touches
something and it turns to gold
[Music]
an atom of gold has 79 protons and 118
neutrons in its nucleus
the electric force of the protons on the
electrons around them
shapes the atom and gives gold its
chemical properties
like that it doesn't rust and that it's
kind of shiny and bendy
so to make not gold into gold we have to
change atoms
let's say midas touches a duck all the
light elements like hydrogen
carbon and oxygen gain electrons and
protons and neutrons to become gold
not only is the duck suddenly 33 times
more massive
it's also much too dense the gold atoms
are far
closer together than they like and repel
each other violently
causing the golden duck to explode with
the energy of half a ton of tnt
leaving only gold dust and a very dead
midas
this is clearly not a very good way for
midas power to work
so what if instead midas power uses the
atoms that are already present
and simply rearranges all particles in
the matter he touches into gold
no matter is created or destroyed
instead atoms dissolve and the protons
neutrons and electrons are reassembled
to make gold however gold is very dense
about 20 times denser than a duck
without adding any matter the gold duck
would be a very awkward kind of foamy
gold with lots of tiny microscopic gaps
this is funky and doesn't explode which
is progress
now that we've established a sort of
magic that works
what would happen if midas stumbles
what if he touches earth itself
let's freeze time for just a moment and
rearrange
all the matter in the earth just like
the duck the earth is now solid gold
but with many tiny atomic scale gaps
while these gaps weren't a huge deal for
the duck they're a big problem for the
earth
a spongy planet is not a thing that can
exist as gravity compresses earth
squeezing it together to close up the
gaps
as a result the earth contracts
shrinking to two-thirds of its radius
if you're standing on earth's surface
you'll suddenly find yourself in free
fall
like on a roller coaster as the ground
sinks away beneath you
but since the ground is falling too it
doesn't move away from you
it feels like someone turned off gravity
and you and everything else would begin
to float
but the ride doesn't last forever it
takes only 10 minutes for everything to
crash down
and a weird 10 minutes it is indeed and
then
as abruptly as it started it stops the
collapsing earth has reached its desired
size
and gravity is suddenly turned back on
for you hopefully you enjoyed your
minutes of floating
because the ground and you with it crash
into the planet
at 30 000 kilometers an hour making your
body spatter like a water balloon
as it hits in one instant basically all
of humanity gets smashed into red
puddles
this is only the start of our problems
though since earth imploded
supersonically
the kinetic energy of the implosion is
basically equivalent to detonating a
planet made of tnt
crushed together under incredible forces
earth's core
reaches a million degrees celsius a
temperature closer to the core of a star
than anything we're used to finding on
earth
as the earth crashes into itself it
generates an enormously powerful shock
wave which plows upwards catapulting the
atmosphere
up and off the earth's surface
temperature reaches hundreds of
thousands of degrees
and everything on it is instantly
vaporized to a fluffy plasma cloud
that starts to expand but not by much
many of the atoms that may have been new
get mixed into this cloud
while others boil off escaping from the
atmosphere
the golden plasma outshines the sun
while the enormous radiation lifts tons
of material
off into space over the coming days the
plasma cloud cools
and eventually freezes into a shiny
little golden ball
okay maybe this type of magic doesn't
work
so if replacing atoms made the earth so
over dense that it exploded
and disassembling and reassembling atoms
made the earth
so under dense that it imploded there
must be a sweet spot where the earth
does neither
what if midas power is such that an
object is suddenly replaced by an
object with the same volume made from
solid gold
that magic is a little bit more magic
and cuts a few extra corners
but let's see where this leads us so
midas stumbles again even though our new
pure gold earth is not expanding or
contracting
it's suddenly much more massive the
density of gold
is three and a half times greater than
the earth meaning the earth
is going to get three and a half times
more massive
for starters everyone now has to contend
with surface gravity
that is more than three times stronger
so if you're not a champion weightlifter
who's used to carrying around a few
times your body weight on your shoulders
you're probably going to be slammed to
the ground by your own weight
depending on where you were when earth
turned into gold this alone could
seriously hurt or even kill you
trees and artificial structures collapse
under stress they were never meant to
sustain
while birds and planes and all things
that were able to fly or float
splash to the ground all around you
and you're not the only thing weighed
down by the greater gravity the weight
of the atmosphere
and also atmospheric pressure nearly
quadrupled which is a bad thing if you
like living
on its own this won't kill you scuba
divers can comfortably breathe air at
these pressures for a while
but unfortunately squeezing the
atmosphere this much raises its
temperature to 150 degrees celsius
which is like the insides of an oven the
entire earth's surface bakes
roasting anything and everything there
is no escape
gold may be a metal but it's about three
times weaker than steel
and also very malleable which makes it
very bad mountain material
the tallest mountains that can be
supported are now only about two
kilometers high
so whole ranges compress as their own
weight basically crushes their base
it's hard to say what happens here we're
probably in for giant earthquakes and
landslides
as the planet is squeezed into a new
shape and it's not just mountain ranges
the differences between the continents
and the ocean floor level out
causing the ocean basins to overflow
sending massive tidal waves over the
earth's surface
what remains is a planet made of gold
entirely covered by an ocean three
kilometers deep
a super hot atmosphere and a lot of dead
people
hmm okay there may be a lesson to take
away here
but we're not sure what it is we did all
the maths though
it's in our sources document if you want
to take a look if you learned anything
in this video let us know what it was
so as you might know the things we sell
in our shop are the reason we're able to
publish videos for free
but it's way more than that for us
here's a short story
and a making of a while ago we posted
this image on social media
just to post something nice looking
immediately a lot of people were quite
upset about it because it was wrong and
you guys take what we put out
that seriously so we've deleted it and
contacted
experts to make something new and better
we spent hundreds of hours on research
and illustration
and created this new extensive map of
evolution a new visualization of the
relationships between living things
that didn't exist before and while this
was obviously a lot of work
and stress it sort of exemplifies why
working on this channel is so satisfying
because you people care and this makes
us work harder
and learn things we didn't know before
so
thank you for supporting our crazy ideas
and our sometimes crazy merch
because of you we can continue to
release our videos for free for everyone
and drop hundreds of hours into new
concepts
we are super grateful for that you can
check out the new evolution poster
among many other things made with love
in our shop
[Music]